[Applause]
so what's the most efficient way to
digest information yeah and so my thing
is always upgrading our skills school
taught us what to learn
what to read what to remember what to
focus on
a lot to what to think yeah but not how
to do those things
you know i think a missing ingredient in
our education system is this thing
called meta learning
okay metal learning means learning how
to learn yes so it's one of those things
school taught us
you know subjects like math and history
and science and spanish
but have been really useful to learn
classes on focus
you know on on study techniques on on
reading faster
and i always thought it should have been
the fourth r in school reading writing
arithmetic
obviously spelling wasn't one of them
but but what about remembering retention
socrates said learning is remembering so
um you know i feel like the trick is to
learn how to learn
and i think it's the biggest superpower
you could have nowadays okay
how do we learn how do we learn more
efficiently more efficiently yeah yeah i
mean we could turn this into masterclass
i mean if people were listening as if
they could grab some notes too
and hopefully drop some practical wisdom
for everybody
you know whether you're in school you're
starting a business wherever you are
um age or stage or your life i would say
um
four keys to learning faster remember
i'll use acronyms just to make it you
know you use acronyms in school of
course
like homes to remember the great lakes
like h's huron oh was ontario there's
like little
tricks i never knew a single lake yeah
yeah yeah
you guys knew the great lakes iran
ontario
michigan erie superior that's amazing
yeah there you go so like homes was like
what mexicans would call each other
gotcha yeah so so so these little things
like um so i remember
fast f-a-s-t these are four tips
learning faster yeah
um so think about a subject or skill you
want to whether it's money marketing
martial arts mandarin whatever right
um the f in fast stands for forget which
is interesting for a memory expert to
talk about but
i feel like a lot of people don't learn
faster because they feel like they know
it already
and our ego could get in the way you
know sometimes so i think sometimes we
have to empty our cup
to put new information in okay so have a
beginner's mind
i would also say forget about
distractions you know
so many people i mean we live in a
culture of rings
dings app notifications social media
alert you know
likes shares comments and we are driven
to distraction
and sometimes it helps to learn when you
can just focus
and if something comes in your mind i
know it's difficult but focus
is a muscle and it's use it or lose it
question about that yeah
i open my phone i can't i imagine
everybody in this room does this
i open my phone to do a single thing
yeah
dove will say hey can you do us a favor
and
text the restaurant and let them know
that we'll be late
i open my phone because i want to do
that
and then i'm on instagram i'm on twitter
i'm like every and then i forgot why i
opened my [ __ ] phone in the first
place
is this just not a useful tool for
executing tasks
you know i i love technology technology
for me
is uh you know it has a light and a dark
side right
like fire is technology fire could cook
your food or fire could burn down your
home
it's just how it's applied i love
technology because it makes our lives
convenient
like it you know soak me allows this to
happen right it allows us to
to reach an impact and encourage and uh
challenge people and i would say that
you want technology
as a tool for you to use but if the
technology is using you
then who becomes the tool yes you know
in the equation and so we're being used
essentially
at some time i would say that use it uh
purposefully
but when you know um i i have on our
podcast we had um
dr bj fogg and he is the he runs a lab
at stanford university yeah
on habits and he's like the number one
habit expert yeah i believe first you
create your habits then your habits
create you but one of his students
actually co-founded instagram and think
about how habitual
that app is right how how addictive it
is
and you know we open it 100 times a day
and if somebody's not opening 100 times
if they're doing it 10 times that means
somebody's opening it a lot more to get
that average
and i'm just saying that for doing it
mindlessly yeah then
it's kind of driving us to distraction
but we're using purpose i'm sure
somebody has
done this analogy before but like you
know in like movies back in the day when
the people who had sex the night before
would wake up the first thing they would
do right is they'd roll over and they'd
grab a cigarette
they light the cigarette and smoke it
right what is the first thing
yeah that we all do the second we wake
up in the morning before i
kiss my fiance yeah i grab my phone
and just oh did we get some likes and
some validation like
i have the validation i need next to me
asleep for the rest of my life but i'm
looking on the phone
did some strangers think i was funny
yesterday it is
so addictive it's terrifying yeah but it
is so
at least for me they've convinced me
it's so useful and it has provided so
much right it's provided
a career for me my friends you know
salvation in a lot of ways in terms of
like uh economic
yeah mobility so it's like it's hard for
me to hate it and it's really hard for
me to tell people not to be on it
yeah like who the [ __ ] am i to say don't
be on your phone when like being on your
phone helped me build this
yep i i think it's a balance i mean so
people i mean and i'm not one to say
for anybody just you know to judge
people should do whatever works for them
and i'm just saying sometimes when we
say yes to somebody or something
make sure we're not saying no to to the
important things
for ourselves you know what i mean that
where
if you're touching your phone the first
thing in the morning
you're rewiring your brain for like
distraction you're rewiring your brain
for reaction to fight fires and respond
to everybody else
as opposed to designing your day you
know around the things that are most
important for you
so i'm not and again i love i'm i'm
online and we we do a lot of things
online
and i would just say having some kind of
balance and so everyone can make a
choice in in my book limitless i have a
quote from a french philosopher and he
says
life is the sea between b and d and you
think about like we're speaking in
tongues b
stands for birth d is death and c life
choice you know i believe that
everything comes down to choices
that our life is a reflection of all the
choices we made up to this point yeah
who are we going to spend time with who
who what we can eat what are we going to
do
and that sum total is where we are today
and we could always at
any time make a new choice and so i'm
saying if you'll have your phone
you know be on your phone and and ask
yourself
is this getting the result that i want
you know so if it's distraction
and you're just doing it people are just
doing it out of habit that's where i'd
be concerned
do you break up and i want to get back
to what you were talking about with
fast and but uh memory
do you break up your
technological devices for the different
things that you use them for like you
have a tablet
just to read so you don't have messages
popping in or
are you able to just do everything there
and you just work that ability enough
yeah
i mean my focus is pretty strong because
i train it and it's a practice so
there's ways we can talk about about
train your focus
yeah most people are training their
distraction muscles so they're flexing
it all the time and they wonder why
they read a page in book and forgot what
they just read they get somebody's name
and it disappears out of their mind they
were gonna say something and they're
like lost that thought
because they're just driven to
distraction because their mind is always
multitasking and trying to do multiple
things
and i would say that if you can control
your environment
yeah it would be great if you could if
you people could afford it to have a
device
just for entertainment and another
device just for work
you know just to help them to focus and
eliminate distractions but it's it's
hard
you know it's that simple but it's that
difficult at the same time
how are we training ourselves for
distraction so
one of the things is especially when you
wake up right when you wake up you're on
this relaxed state and you're
very very suggestible right and so if
you pick up your phone
you're you're rewiring your brain for
distraction because like we talked about
every like share comment cat video
whatever
it just you get this dopamine flood
right and dopamine gives you happiness
and it
it goes along the learning and
motivation centers of your nervous
system and that's what makes it
addictive
right you just want more and more and
more and and keep in mind
like these platforms have invested
countless dollars billions of dollars
they have the best like psychologists to
be able to engineer
uh spending more time and again it's
just
giving people free will and choice so i
would say that
having this device there you know as
much as you can be able to control
it and exercise your your your will and
as long as it's not taking you from a
way
like distraction the opposite is
traction
right and so if you're making traction
in your life in your career in your
business in school
distraction is things that take you away
from that path and so i would just
ask yourself is this giving me what i
want in the moment and it's
it's not easy at all right it's it's
very addictive
we have videos online where we talk
about just even having a phone at a
dinner table stresses people out
their anxiety goes up even if it's face
down you just feel the
you know the the the drive to pick it up
yeah
yeah it's uh it is so true there's two
phones on the table a buddy of mine like
janice papa has a funny joke about this
but uh
that i'm not going to butcher right now
because i don't remember it
unfortunately
but um but yeah having the phone on the
tables like you're in this conversation
and if that conversation lags at all
your eyes just start like drifting to
that
thing that can make you feel good in the
moment hmm
so they're hiring people like you
essentially to do
bad things so you're you're a force of
good
you're like hey be careful guys this is
how you should live your life and this
is how we can optimize
our brain and not be tricked by these
scientists that are basically going how
do we trick people
i i would say that um i don't know i
won't talk about conspiracies but i'm
just saying that
we we have to be 100 responsible for our
life we're now we're not a victim or at
the effect
okay and as much as as you know control
we could have in directing in the course
as opposed to
you know being at the effect and then
yeah
here's my question yeah if you can get
me addicted to my phone
can that same technology get me addicted
to working out
can it get no yeah yeah yeah oh it can
be worse yeah
it's the same principles well let's
[ __ ] go i mean is that what peloton
is is that what like
soul cycle and all the things that
people get like big rushes from yeah
yeah yeah i would love
you know for me it's always habits is
all about
making what's good for you easy and
what's making
what's bad for you more difficult like
if picking up the phone is really
driving you
to you know in putting a wedge between
you and your relationship
or your health or your work then you
know ideally
don't have the phone in the in the
bedroom if you can help it because then
that just makes it easier it's just like
let's say somebody doesn't feel good
when they eat bread but they love bread
and and the waitstaff brings bread to
the table it's easier to say
no up front than having it sit there and
just like no
no 50 times during dinner right and so
set up the environment for you to win
yeah i think that'd be pretty pretty
[Applause]
wise